Now, here's another thing that I'm
really impressed with.
Pope Leo visited Haga Sophia but did not
pray in it. Impressive.
Impressive.
They said that
Pope Francis and Pope Benedict went
there and prayed there. He did not.
Impressive.
Very impressed.
Too much stuff. I can't keep up.
My throat will get better by the power
of the Holy Spirit through your prayers
for me in Jesus name.
All right. I don't know what that's
about.
Let's go here. My profile.
Yep. I posted this. But here is another
interesting thing.
Catholic sat.
Let's go right here. The pope meeting
with the Greek Orthodox patriarchal
church of St. George and Estanbul. Pope
Leo 14th leads the Orthodox in reciting
their father in Latin. Wow.
[clears throat] People are going to get
upset at this. They're going to see this
as compromise and ecumenism.
Right.
If I'm going to get upset at this, there
it goes. Rumble.
There you go.
[clears throat] Right.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Why would I need to be careful?
Okay, we don't need to ask. At the Greek
Orthodox Patriarchal Church of St.
Georgian estumble. Pope Leo IVth leads
the Orthodox ring the our father in
Latin. All right.
You have those folks who are going to
get angry.
We want the ancient churches to become
one again.
one again. But those who
are tools of Satan,
you have Catholics that are like that,
set aists, and you have these Orthodox
that are like that
that condemn this because they feel it's
satanic. It's a work of Satan. So,
all right. But it is actually an answer
to the prayer of the Lord Jesus Christ.
See, here you go. A demon tool of Satan.
The Diamond Brothers, right? Vatican
Catholic.com. See, you have dogs
[clears throat] in all denominations.
These dogs condemn all popes and all
churches to hell. No one is saved except
their cult. The Diamond Sisters. Right
there. You see Vatican Catholic.com
sunjint prayer with the leader of a
heretical sect has always been forbidden
by true Catholic teaching. You see and
valid popes see that the diamond sisters
these dogs of Satan ch from Roma.
See so you have dogs in every branch of
Christianity
because according to these heretics no
one is saved but their group. Everyone
goes to hell except their group because
[clears throat] they don't know God.
They don't know the father. They don't
know the son, the lord Jesus Christ.
They don't know the holy spirit. They
don't know the biblical God. One thing I
can tell you guys, part of my journey,
the more I read, and I'm being honest,
[clears throat]
and coming from me, as you can see, I
cuss people out and all that. You think
that's weird, right? The more I
read and read about God's character, his
nature [clears throat and cough]
in the Old and New Testaments, the more
I saw his heart,
the more I realized Calvinism is from
the pit of hell, five point of Cal pit
of hell. And any view of God that makes
him appear as a God who doesn't love all
creatures and desires the salvation of
all is not the God of scripture but a
satanic counterfeit.
And the more
I studied how God goes out of his way
to save [clears throat] the unrighteous,
even the wicked, pleading with them to
repent.
and how God in his heart will even
excuse
the Gentiles who to no fault of their
own did not have the gospel and
overlooked their ignorance and see among
them those who responded to the little
light that was given to them that he
would save them on the merits of Jesus
Christ save them because of Jesus. The
more I realized these guys are dogs who
do not know the heart of God.
The more I realized that, the more I
came to appreciate Nostraate
lumenentium [clears throat]
and what the catechism says, just to
give you an example what I mean here.
Here is the heart of God revealed in
Paul. Here's the heart of God revealed
in Paul.
Pray for me, the Holy Spirit, reign me
in. Restrain me. Constrain me. I'm going
to try not to insult, but I will fail.
So bear with me and forgive me. I'm
going to try not to use very harsh
language in Jesus name unless absolutely
necessary. I hope at least dog won't
upset you and son of Satan.
So let's go into the heart of God a
little more so I can help you
understand. Go watch my series on
whether Catholics, Muslims, Orthodox
worship and adore the same God.
Only if I have to necessarily.
I'm trying not to because we have people
like Chloe saying, "Oh, I wish you
didn't cuss out." Well, Chloe, I wish
you were tough, man. But what can I do,
Chloe? You're too soft. By the way, it
was her birthday yesterday, right?
All right. Now,
Rumble, you ready?
Okay. You ready? Let's see if the screen
is large enough. All right.
Yeah. And then Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Rumble, you ready? Here's the heart of
God. Now, [clears throat] while Paul
waited for them at Athens, go watch a
series where I use this. And this is
quoted by the Eastern Orthodox and the
Catholic Church.
His spirit was provoked within him as he
saw the city full of idols. Now,
remember what Paul said in 1 Corinthians
10 19 to 22, specifically 1 Corinthians
10:20. He says that
attached idols are demons.
Demons
are energizing idolatry. Okay, that's
what he says. Quoting Deuteronomy
32:16-17,
right? Psalm 106:36-37.
as the spirit gives me perfect recall of
the scriptures
even though they're steeped in idolatry
and under the influence of demons. So he
reasoned in the synagogue with
[clears throat] the Jews and devout
persons in the marketplace every day
with those who met him. Some of the
Epicurian and Stoic philosophers also
were conversing with him. Some said,
"What does this blab babler want to
say?" Now I'm not going to go line by
line,
but watch here. Others said he seems to
be advocating
sorry guys the caffeinated drinks makes
you burp
foreign deities because he preach Jesus
the resurrection. They took hold of him
and brought him to the Aropagus Marcel
saying may we know what this new
teaching is which you are speaking about
for [clears throat] you bring certain
strange things to our ears. We want to
know therefore what these things mean.
Now all the Athenians and the strangers
living there spent their time in nothing
else but either to tell or to hear some
new thing. In other words, they were the
CNN of the first century.
Okay, now watch here.
They were the CNN of the first century.
The latest gossip scandal, that's what
they're into. Paul stood in the middle
of the Aropagus and said, "You men of
Athens, I perceive that you are very
religious in all things." Now notice,
Paul does not condemn them outright.
Does not rebuke [clears throat] them for
being pagans, heathens, sons of Satan
going to hell. Okay? That's not the
approach.
And I've mentioned it and I'll mention
it again. I need you to listen. The
approach is you come graciously,
lovingly, patiently.
You win them with the love of Jesus
Christ. That's the normal way of doing
things. That's the approach. Love them.
Be gracious to them. Be patient with
them because you assume they are
ignorant.
They don't know any better. Okay?
You are religious in all things. For as
I pass along and observe the object of
worship, notice he doesn't say they're
religious because of their idolatry.
He says you are religious because
you are aware of this God that you are
ignorant of. You know he's there but you
don't know much about him
and you know that he exists.
You know that he he exists.
Are you listening?
Listen guys, please focus. I'm trying to
help you learn your faith. As you pray
for me, God, forgive me of my sins,
wickedness, and not destroy me and damn
me to hell as I deserve
for my unintentional willful sins. May I
hate what God hates and hate my flesh.
Not there yet, unfortunately.
Okay. Why does he say religious? Because
he says, "For
as I saw your object worship, I saw you
at an altar to an unknown god." So, you
are aware there's a god beyond your
gods.
You're aware that there's a God out
there,
right, that's a cause of these things,
but you don't know much about him. Now,
this destroys the arguments of those
that say, "Well, when you're approaching
Muslims, go watch my series. You can't
say their God is your God." Why can't
you say that?
Because what does Paul say? This God
that you are aware is there but you
don't know much about him
and you want to appease him. This is the
God I'm going to announce to you. What
therefore you worship in ignorance I
announce to you. Note he says they are
worshiping him but in an ignorant
ignorant meaning they're doing their
best with the little revelation given to
them to worship this god in order to
appease him though they don't know much
about him and they don't know the
fullness of the truth and the proper way
of worshiping him.
You understand that right there?
rumble.
So, as I said in my previous series,
Muslims don't know the Quran, don't know
the [clears throat] Sunnah. Like all
people, they're born into religious
tradition. They're ignorant of it. Like
Catholics are ignorant of Catholic
teaching. Orthodox are ignorant of
Orthodox teaching. Even we Assyrians
had an educated, informed Assyrian
priest
taught me the faith when I was young, I
wouldn't have ventured off into Baptist
theology and later returned to Baptist
and then evangelical and then Calvinist
theology. But sadly, most of the
Assyrian priests were ignorant. They
didn't know their Bible. They didn't
know their tradition.
I don't know why you can't open my blog.
You want me there?
So this means
God will look into
your heart and see how you respond to
that little light you have. So he goes
look he says you are worshiping my God
but you're doing it in ignorance because
you don't know him fully and you don't
know what his will is completely.
Do we see that there?
I want you to see this. This is in Acts
17, man.